eldon ring's millennia has changed again
ps5 finally has variable refresh rate
and more
in a previous patch elden ring's hardest
boss fight millennia was accidentally
made more difficult that patch let her
regain health from attacks even when she
made contact with nothing but air given
her two phases and ability to kill you
with just one good string of attacks
this made the fight borderline
impossible thankfully fromsoft has
remedied the situation according to the
1.04 patch notes the new update fixed a
bug with millennia in which her hp was
not healed correctly in the online
multiplayer environment i still haven't
gotten to her yet in my playthrough but
this is pretty good to hear and i also
hope let me solo her still active once i
do get to that point other changes
include a vague fix for a bug that
caused some bosses to die at unintended
times meaning our days of cheesing could
be coming to an end but fingers crossed
that they're not completely over yet and
in other update news or lack thereof
ps5s now have variable refresh rate
support earlier this week sony announced
that vrr support would be coming to the
playstation 5 through a new firmware
update but it seems this feature is
already waiting to be used on your
console many users have found that vrr
is in fact already available on the ps5
presumably added to the console via the
previous update but kept deactivated
until now a simple reboot of your ps5
should let you access the feature via
the playstation 5's display settings
menu allowing you to enable it if you
have the console connected to a
supported display by default vrr is
enabled only for games that officially
support it with sony releasing a list of
games like miles morales and ratchet and
clink rift apart that have already
received patches to work with the
feature you can also enable a toggle
that lets vrr be used at a system level
and apply to all games although sony
warns that its performance might vary or
not appear at all on a game by game
basis and while we're on the subject of
playstation the ps plus leak was correct
and starting may 3rd subscribers can
grab fifa 22 curse of the dead gods and
tribes of midgard for free so mark your
calendars but wait the update news
doesn't stop there grand theft auto 5 on
ps5 and series xns has added some
welcome updates which while seemingly
minor go a long way in improving the
nearly decade old game the biggest
change is a new motion blur slider
allowing players to tone down or
completely turn off motion blur making
car gameplay look more crisp and
detailed the ability to customize the
game's motion blur is something that
fans have requested since the new
versions launched with the effect
becoming way more intrusive at higher
frame rates the update also fixed the
bug on xbox where in-game music would be
muted when players were in an xbox live
party as well as a handful of other
issues affecting audio on the xbox
players have also reported finding new
improvements including new options for
displaying and hiding activities on the
map and fix shadows on new gen xbox
consoles players have also discovered
that the new gen update files are also
present on pc though are currently empty
suggesting that the update will come to
pc at some point in the near future so
do you like to play your games with
motion blur on or off let me know in the
comments below and then head over to
twitter and wish my internet father greg
miller a happy birthday he turns 21
today and it's pretty cool that he
finally gets to drink legally i'll see
you tomorrow
[Music]